if BN wins the people win that is the
campaign message from barisa National
the national front wooing voters with
Promises of stability and prosperity
the right-wing Coalition had ruled
Malaysia since Independence in 1957 but
anger about government corruption led to
its first defeat in the last general
election
we have to tackle this perception manage
this perception getting rid of
corruption is something barusa National
is committed to it's not just a rhetoric
the allegations tamed many of its top
politicians including leader Ahmad zahid
hamidi who's on trial for money
laundering and bribery
former chairman najib Raza who served as
prime minister for nearly 10 years has
been jailed for corruption linked to the
Looting of State investment fund 1mdb he
faces more trials in connection with the
multi-billion dollar Financial scandal
both men say that victims of political
persecution
the Coalition returned to power in 2020
after defections led to the collapse of
the then-ruling alliance since then it
has won two State polls and several by
elections buoyed by this its leaders
pushed for early elections but analysts
say corruption remains an important
issue for voters in many voters still
realize that the change that came in
2018 the court cases and the final
jailing of former prime minister najib
Raza is just the beginning of what is
supposed to be an ongoing process of
cleaning up government and putting
things back in order that job is
unfinished economists say Malaysians
will be paying the price of corruption
for years to come
it destroyed the confidence that you
have on institutions and I think the
moral corruption is much bigger impact
because more long-lasting one plus is
broken tour again is very difficult
opposition politicians have capitalized
on this warning that a vote for the
national front is a vote for corruption
this is the first time voters will have
a choice between more than two strong
coalitions surveys suggest no one party
will secure a simple majority on its own
a hung Parliament means alliances will
have to be forged and that means not
only is this election too close to call
but it would be unwise to rule out any
possibilities
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur